the
whole harmless is five years and the
full transition to 95 from 70 is 10
years that's the way it's written
um and
you know you put the pieces of the
puzzle together and
um in those first five years
um communities will be protected
although less and less because the
transition grants can be phasing out too
so you really have to look at how it
plays out municipality by municipality
to see
to see and understand it's important
so the transition money goes maybe you
notice Gambino transition money is going
to communities that now keep the exit
swept
uh I believe I I believe that's right oh
yeah
the other way around
starting at 70.
it's 70 percent of the of the new new
calculated Foundation Opportunity Grant
is what they'll get at the beginning and
a excess swept
town that under the new calculations
would still get more money from swept
than it would get from this grant would
Jefferson Woodcock did you have your
um
so the grant that coming in
and assuming through the new
autonomics here
during the five year period is that
where they are right now
and they'll always need to apply me that
finding a great at that level five
minutes remind me to do whatever the new
level is well the actual the
transitional Grant phases out so it's a
hundred percent in the first year of the
Gap okay and then 80 of the Gap and 60
and so on and the Gap is is changing too
because you're also having a sloping up
of the grant
you got to put the two together and see
are there questions of Representative
Ames no no but you're welcome to sit
there because I'm sure there will be
on this bill
before we made a decision to
infrastructure yeah
Jay gave us
suggestions
that's what I was hoping that when we
have Dave next that we can do that
that's why I think we need one more
meeting I had suggestions that I'm I'm
not quite agreeable to the weighted
formula
for this special education
when we're having a weighted Formula
Four Point
something I think four point let's call
4.1 of that and still called the base
but that amount which they're
multiplying by
for all 13 categories
um
I think that
well that was part of the the amendment
we had for the extraordinary needs which
was at that time it was Senator
Kennedy's Hennessey's bill
and I was trying to get a better handle
it well it was unanimous in our
committee
passed the house on consent
went and that was stripped in house
finance
that Amendment
although house finance chair did say to
me now the chair of Finance she agrees
that a weighted factor is something that
I would say over half the states use
right now uh to you know be able to
allocate that appropriation out to
schools for various categories you know
and I know that they're categories which
are
are require a lot more
um
assistance uh throughout the day you
know support to the child and and uh and
expertise which is above and beyond
reading and language uh in in
mathematics
they're really some of
relation along with the other health
impaired we're seeing right now which
you're dealing with uh I don't want to
call them Behavior because behavior is
something is learned and it's not
necessarily always been an IEP category
however emotional issues and all which
have been developed are now
significant in causing disruptions where
chairs are flying around some of the
classrooms and
you have to evacuate the classroom and
before you can get a good handle on it
that's certainly disrupting things
yes
uh yeah I just I just I I passed out to
the committee this uh
article called The Tale of uh two
schools
and I just happened to find this article
as I was rummaging through stuff
this is an article that appeared in a
conquered monitor March 1984.
38 years ago
and it compares
Hopkinton High School
with Pittsfield High School
now you'll note the lovely young lady
that's sitting in the lower part just
happens to be my daughter
but I I read this article and I was
saying to myself whoa not much has
changed in 38 years
as a matter of fact if you were to
compare pittsfield's high school and
Hopkinton high school today
the situation would be worse than it was
38 years ago
and so that's just one point the other
point I wanted to make too Rick was uh
when we had the uh education oversight
committee meeting last week
we had uh representatives from the
Department there
and they uh basically reviewed their is
it called what's it called I platform
yeah their eye platform
and they have populated that with all
kinds of data
much of the same data that we use in the
commission actually
and I went up I went up to uh Dr Green
afterwards
and asked him if he if the basically the
data came from the the form 25 that the
school district submit
and in fact it does
and my point is is that if you look to
see where we are today
with the information that's available
the data that's available
the
um the the progress of students data
that's available
if none of that was none of that was was
there when the original input model was
created years ago
like 38 years ago
and it just seems to me that we now have
an opportunity
to take that significant data dump that
they've got
to begin to look at a different way of
funding schools
to make sure that the at least as a
commission has suggested
that the current funding that we have
available for schools from the state
that it then be allocated in a different
format
than just the one size fits all that we
have right now
and I'm not trying to be critical of the
original
structure that was created because
that's what we had
I mean that's all we had was how many
deaths do you have what's the average
teacher salary what's the benefit
package what's the how many nurses yet I
mean all that stuff was the only thing
we had at the time that we created the
current system
now
we have a full plethora
of data that's available
that can be used in a much more I
believe and much more significant way to
begin to really look at student
achievement
all schools are doing
um and the other thing that I think
that's implicit in this bill
is a much higher accountability
of how the money is being spent
you don't have much accountability when
you get four thousand dollars per kid
across the board
you don't know what happens to that
money
with the concept of this provides a much
greater detailed accountability
of how the money is being spent and
where there are problems
it's incumbent upon the school district
then to create a plan upon which to deal
with those students that's student
population
that needs to become more competitive
and they have greater outcomes Etc
so um I would just my comment was I took
from our meeting that we had last week
just the data that's available now that
that was just wasn't there before that
that we should be able to use
to provide a much more robust
manual with which we basically create a
funding system
thank you well just to tag in on that
Mel
um
from that meeting we have with the
legislative oversight committee for
those here we were looking at one of the
issues which we brought up was we know
that over the last
14 years that I've been here
um that we've seen a slide
in
mathematics achievement
at the middle school level
and we've also seen that occur
even more rapidly since the pandemic and
we know all the issues with the pandemic
my concern that I brought up was we know
what the minimum standards for public
school approval are how many on this
committee have actually seen the
academic standards that this state has
Fred that's okay there there you go the
Frameworks are not to be considered that
the Frameworks are basically guidelines
and we no longer have Frameworks nor do
we have those guidelines my concern is
that
when we were looking for accountability
we're using and I'm I'm a Believer in
statistics and and state assessments or
assessing to determine there's a lot of
different ways of doing it some schooly
districts do it with their own locally
developed diagnostic instruments like
the star math or the nwea or some other
type of instrument for assessment and
they do that periodically through the
school year
they are measuring
with an instrument that they feel most
closely reflects what their curriculum
is and what their instruction is in
terms of the sequence that that
instruction occurs within that high
school or that middle school or
Elementary School
we are assessing what the Statewide
assessment
and we know we have that assessment
supposed to be built around our
standards
and but curriculum is a local
responsibility
and when you teach it this year or the
following year so we don't know if
necessarily that those local curriculums
are aligned with this instrument we're
using to assess with many districts and
in fact I was just working with a group
in a school district this last week they
they prefer to use their own assessment
they have to use the Statewide but they
have their own assessments because they
know that's measuring what they are in
fact are teaching
so I think there's a to a degree there's
a disconnect in in the information we're
getting back
and when we do get it back how engaged
are we in working with those school
districts to try and show those places
we need to to gain and I don't know if
standardized tests didn't necessarily
measure what children will learn in
school and I got involved in the state
foreign
so if a teacher was spending all her
time in second grade teaching the
children about tents and and adding with
making kids all those questions on the
stuff that they basically teach would be
eliminated because too many kids Library
it was today was taken as being too easy
and too many kids because too many kids
got right which left the testing and the
questions to be all the kinds of things
that we didn't spend a long time it's in
second grade for example teaching so it
has always been that Gap even with the
tests that the state uses
there has to be a better way of
assessing how a job is learning and
whether the child is they've got
cheating at the maximum level for that
Child Benefits
or something that's one size fits all
but once you have different tests
different methods being used in
different districts then you lose in
your ability to compare you know
so it's really important
okay that's 22 in my opinion so I would
really love to see it
measuring the results of school other
than
just
my little lunch for today
yeah we could talk forever on testing we
could
um
why people have chosen
well I think that accountability when we
say accountability is the strength of
this
I'd like to ask the questions exactly
how are you going to hold these
districts accountable
what's the process and what's the
process to make sure they're coming out
with that performance outcome that we're
seeking based upon
the fact that snapshots always does well
in comparison to the rest of the states
and using the norm reference test that
we use
but how do we you know how do we you
know
understand that the results
are reflecting the curriculum that's
being taught I don't know in terms of
that's a local decision and do we have
the oversight from doe to ensure that
you are teaching the curriculum the
academic standards that we set for the
state
must have prevent a teacher from closing
the door and saying I'm going to do my
thing
I don't know if we ever get to that
accountability we're looking for in the
dollars this is just basically
we're looking at averages here
we're not looking at individuals
yeah
what happens in the future
I think I talked about that a while ago
when what happens from the kids we the
system
and that's what in my opinion up smooth
Sports to make sure that we have
students going out into the world or
preparing for and also appear to be
citibully those are the most of our
calls came back and rocks you know
anybody gets education so they can move
up to the ladder and everybody learns
how system works so they don't get Swept
Away by another one
and
but we don't do that what we do to a
degree don't we we we have the
performance indicators that are reported
at the end of the year annually dealing
with discipline with the ASVAB how they
test out in the military I'm going to go
on the post-secondary education
disciplinary issues
um all there there must be a good 13 of
those indicators that we we measure
along with the Statewide achievement
tests
no we have it every year when we get
well we have it based upon yeah our
graduation those are a graduation but we
also have grades three through eight and
I'm not consistent across the state in
terms of when the instruction of being
except for the youngster so the state go
on to test is still going to show you
how he did but they may not receive that
information again
so which becomes then timing with the
German level of accountability that
representative miles talking about that
that has affected by the results of the
academic testing is the Baseline
academic testing is not going to
situation yeah they're trying to do it
that way but that's not raise the
is that
you're not we have multiple purpose then
then you can use you can use a state
more funding or less money based on
Halloween
if those local curriculums
yeah I don't know if they do right now
or not that's that how will we ever
determine and learn that
[Music]
but when when I was doing this studying
studying about this when we talk about
the national tests and the international
tests I would always support So formally
in mathematics it was pointed out yeah
if the test was given say in eighth
grade then our students scored below the
kids from Finland it's because the kids
can Finland and already had algebra and
our kids didn't get until next year so
it was that that same kind of thing that
Steve was talking about when it was
taught wasn't that our kids
were not cheating they just weren't
cheating in a subject that they hadn't
learned yet
um you know I remember the social
studies and the tests that they had in
the 11th grade
um
that's that's exactly why
a number of years ago we took the
responsibility for assessing social
studies away from the state and handed
it down to the local districts to have
an assessment done that's in statute
right now
but you know in terms of
trying to to
target funds to help those groups and
those areas which need that support I
can remember we had a program called
math learning communities
and that program was one which was
initiated through bathorian over at the
community college system over nhdi
and at the end of the 10th grade
or towards the end we would
have the um what do they call it then
the accuplacer the Next Generation
accuplacer which was was done at that
time for going all over the
post-secondary education through the
community college level we were also
administering it for under this grant
program to students coming out of
Algebra 1 in the 10th grade
those that scored a 63 or lower were
seen by the teacher by parent and by the
others in the school as probably going
to have a difficult time going into
algebra 2. so then the option was
available to go to either course one
which was an advanced mathematics which
was built on learning style and and and
teaching style and more of a Hands-On
and and it brought all a different way
of teaching in and then there was if
they had a 63 or lower they went into
that if they had a score which is
similar a little bit higher they they
could go into what they called
quantitative math later on in the fourth
year which was the course two which they
would get the credit for the
post-secondary math requirement
um we had about 35 high schools involved
in with that the funding has now stopped
and the program even though it's on the
books and statute is no longer used and
I talked to Beth this morning following
our meeting
I said why why are we not doing it she
said it's all about funding we made a
lot of progress and we were seeing an
increase of pure or a decrease of
remedial students coming in the
post-secondary education which at that
time we had 60 percent that needed
remedial mathematics and post-secondary
in the associates degree and of that of
that 60 percent 50 percent never got the
associate's degree but spent money
trying and so it was lost time lost
effort lost money and so there's a
program which was obviously doing
something that
when the grant stopped there was no
money available for teacher training
there was no money for materials and
it's kind of dissolved even though it's
on the books and stats right now I think
it's 194 colon
I I think
there's a small title there which
so back to funding that's also funding
I I'd like to have if if we could have
Dave give some more feedback to us how
this hat works for the Swap and how this
transition really unfolds
see so we can see we had a spreadsheet I
don't have mine with me today yeah we
did have one but to take us through that
I got at the house so I I can look at it
but I was hoping that we could go
no there was a spreadsheet that he had
which showed how this impacted
everywhere in the state all districts
feels very pretty
the other other part of the equation
which I wrote when I was on the study
commission with you representative Myler
was how do we measure the effectiveness
of leadership in the building
I'm a strong proponent that strong
leadership
is necessary to have strong growth in
achievement
from the student side
how do you measure that how do we know
that the the the schools you may have
some schools which are
getting decent funding Lisa doe 25 form
reflects it but their scores are not
there
why
is that one of those non-tangibles
aspiration of the community
it's interesting I was talking to a
friend of mine a young teacher
and he has a new principle this year
and he just was excited I mean he was he
was visibly excited
about what she was doing how she was
doing it not not the one that he retired
was bad at all he was good too but it
was just nice I can't see
a teacher who was just excited about
what he was saying and experiencing and
feeling
with this new administrator that he had
and um you're right I don't know how you
measure it other than
you know you have to measure I would
think you have to look to see how the
kids do old I think that the ultimate
the ultimate test to me is how the kids
are performing
and uh how do we provide the support in
those areas that they're not before and
I think that's that's been my concern
since I've been on this committee and
that is how do you help school districts
that need additional resources whether
it be
fiscal standpoint or from the Personnel
standpoint or the actual curriculum that
that's that's a concern that I have
and I and I think frankly what we're
talking about here in 1680
can get to that because right now I I
just don't see I don't see the
accountability there for how we fund
schools I mean
everybody gets the same amount of money
that's it you get the check that's it
how do we
how do we provide some incentives for
people to
to perform and give kids
an equal opportunity across the state
about the weather
what he told me was the constitution of
the state requires all children
receive a saint it's the Constitution
says they have to voluntary evil
and that was the reason why when they
were talking about
um
formulas he was in women why it ended up
with everybody with the same it's
because you couldn't
you couldn't we give more to one
Community than to another because it was
unconstitutional student
does anybody know anything about that
does that ever come up with any of the
discussions or was it just a private
conversation in the United
it comes out of the Londonderry and
Claremont cases that's where all evolved
from
and you cannot
uh discriminate in your funding due to
the
the wealth of a community their poverty
or that you've got the they all deserve
the same base amount
and then it's made up differently and
that formula came out in 2000 eight
had physical capacity just variate when
in it and that's where they use
something likened to the equalized
property valuation and the medium family
income to whether a municipality
qualified for additional money outside
of the basic adequacy which was what
three thousand
456 something like that and and
differentiated a that's your adequacy
amount right there everything
and that money's not it's sent to the
school district and it's not targeted
otherwise differentiated aid for special
education within that differentiated Aid
it can be used Any Which Way
um along with the English language
learner and the special education there
was a category for special education
issue recall on that based on poverty
and when it got up to 48 or a higher
poverty in your school you got another
whole base amount on top of that for
each child in that school
that formula in itself was I thought a
very good formula we never funded it
properly
in fact that's the formula I was who was
the senator at that time that was did
that um I wasn't here I was in Alaska at
the time but
um I felt during the commission study
she was on the the commission
yeah
no not Nancy
now
yeah start with an s
likes but
um
I'll think of it but uh I thought that
that you know when I was in a commission
study I would like to see us really just
along with the organ book formula if we
funded things properly all along we
parents who are well educated from New
York have come up to walk to New
Hampshire to live a slight in the 19th
my mother-in-law wrote
talking about the importance of funding
education to get the state of New
Hampshire in 1951
it's the same problem
yeah if you need another one down for
represent Hall
I think that today we can you know there
are certain things we can agree upon
um I some of the funding mechanisms and
I have some problems with but one thing
I can agree upon is this is the data
report that I put together back when we
were doing the subsequent study with uh
representative umberger where I try to
identify
by quartiles here on the Equis property
valuation per pupil and you can see
there on on group number one there where
they have less than 660 000 per pupil
there were a total of 26 uh
municipalities in that quartile
and or in that group and you can see
that in quartile 1 and quartile 2
you had and that's as we look at the one
two three and four one and two are below
proficiency on our Statewide assessment
now so one and two on this are also but
the quartile wise so it
um you can see that there's 85 percent
of the students in those 85 percent of
those districts the students were in
quartiles one and two
when associated with dollars if you go
all the way up to group four
and you look at those which have one
million dollars plus per pupil on
equalized property valuation
you can see that there are 73 percent or
excuse me that no there's there's uh 70
60 percent
of the students are in Courthouse three
and four
so it shows that there is is
relationship
and these this was taken out of our old
achievement test which we have the
Statewide hasn't changed a lot that it
shows that there's a relationship
that's something we went into the whole
study knowing that
and I I don't think there's any denying
that
there's a lot of other variables but
this is one of the outcomes right here
yeah
that's a separate category I I pull them
out and you can see that
in of the 13 cities 11 of them are in
quartiles one and two
and there were what two cities in three
Incorporated Manchester National
Franklin Berlin
yeah
significance yeah and population
the two cities the two cities in the
lebanon's way up
it says a group of information in the
case that cities are more likely to have
high numbers of low performing students
regardless equalized valuation Keen
enforcements being the exception
according to this data
those were the two at that time which
were just not reflecting what the other
2018.
and we used it in that study back then
to come up with recommendations and this
was also shared during the commission
study
and it kind of echoed what air
invest more than students
be more of their investment
moving forward
successfully
that's what appears to with crows and
achievement
you have to invest more
to bring those folks in quadrupt wanting
to up
and I think I think so quite a while on
that point Steve what the commission was
doing
was taking the current amount of money
that has been allocated to fund schools
and but allocating it in a different
format to deal with exactly what you're
talking about and those areas that had
greater need
that that's where some more funds need
to go in there with with the
accountability function in there I think
it was what
five years there was a five-year time
frame
for schools that were low performing
to begin to turn around because you
can't turn around schools just overnight
I mean it takes time
but it deals with the leadership it
deals with the funding and that's what
the commission was talking to us how do
you take that current amount of money
not additional money in the pool you
take that pool of money
and you basically allocate it in a
different kind of a way than what we're
well it's also imperative that you're
you're measuring what you're teaching
foreign
no but there's there's a lot of
contributors to what we're doing and
what we're trying to fund and I I
believe that any any kind of
recommendation I would offer is a
supplement to up or down to the up I
would also say that there's
like the academic standards how do we
ensure that the the tests we're using is
measuring the academic standards as
taught in that particular school we do
not have control over instruction and
curriculum and so you Mr principal would
be teaching something U.S history at a
different grade level than what this
instrument would be measuring so your
kids would never show it but it doesn't
mean they're not walking out the door at
but see I don't want to be funding
though a lot of money based upon some
data we're getting which is not
reflective of the quality of teaching
you've just mentioned representative
Miler that that there was a change in
leadership princip in the school and
kids are excited teachers are excited
that's exactly the same occurrence
that's occurring in Woodsville high
school right now we have a young man
that came in from across the from
Vermont and and has just turned the page
on that school as far as attitude and
aspiration of students involvement of
parents involvement of the staff in the
schools there's ownership in what
they're doing
it's not status quo and that's something
I don't think you can that that's not
something that money necessarily is
going to pay if this guy came from the
Leadership School attitude and teacher
attitude and all those things are
it might be but today the high Works in
here worldwide right right what he is
then we have
the thing we have in our philosophy is
it makes no sense to me to continue to
keep on doing the same thing over and
over and over and over again
and extracted results I mean there's so
much
I mean it just doesn't make any sense to
do that but we now it's time to move and
then at least we have a plan to try
something to improve it if we go back
and say well we have to worry about how
the principal is going to the
I think we have to take a step and say
you know what
we have to move because what we're doing
we know is not working it's not working
to make audiences in New Hampshire
educated and want to stay in New
helps me more than anything because the
fact that we need to make sure that New
Hampshire improves and that this this
current method of this like this current
method does not work but that work when
we did this
but we've gone past that series
[Music]
but we can't hold this up way for the
social emotional types of variables
and Leadership and goes back to
effective typical things
like this
they stopped potatoes we go back to
college you know quit until we stopped I
mean
yes
but you know what we would use to
determine whether a school or students
were being successful or not
um
and it is struggling we've talked about
the adhdi
with Beth Norm uh in that 63 percent off
they used on the activist where the
students come in most of the students
going into the community college system
who were below 63 they know exactly what
13 of the kids going into the community
college system are testing to below 63
or even lower and then the issue becomes
okay what's and that's not an issue what
did we teach out for the ninth graders
that is those those are people who met
the whatever the full range was that
they could yeah in high school and
that's good
CBS the the agriculture nhti
they don't store it become
smaller Partners but they're ways of
figuring out
you know starting I think starting to
get into what what are specifics of high
school my schools in this case didn't
need to be looked at and that's just
just the math that's just the math let's
just look here
thank you I think that um where you're
hitting on this issue of accountability
and using the data we have that should
be something that when we look at and
hear that the strength of this bill is
that these performance outcomes and then
there will be accountability I I think
the question has to be always asked what
how are you going to get that
accountability what how are you going to
discern it is it going to be based on
the data that's submitted every year to
doe which shows the number of kids in
this category this category in this
category or is there going to are we
going to actually take something like
bathorian had a community college system
and go back and find out okay these are
the places these students are coming
from and I wouldn't be surprised that if
you had some schools which had kids
coming like that that came out of
schools which have the dollars to
deliver a a pretty good education
otherwise it wouldn't be just all poor
communities
if if 60 of the kids arrive in the
community college system we're we're not
proficient in mathematics that's a
deeper deeper issue and by throwing
money at something do we always repair
it
not always you know we want to get to
those efficiencies and good use of our
dollars and see the student achieve I
think there are some
non-dollar issues which highly
contribute to Performance of students
and we can't negate that
and don't think that this is going to be
the fix to it all I don't think it's
going to be the fix to it all
right president Porter had her hand up
first
most likely students coming from
foreign College
[Music]
would be not all over the place but
someone who has issues paying for
college
because they're
you know I'm standing
would not be like me
to choose to go someplace they can't
afford blockages get out of high school
and go to community clubs
and would that be an indicator there's a
lot of kids that are not performing
mathematically like they should at the
community college level
a function of the high school not a
paranormal
enough function of
of socioeconomic status influencing
um
the rich the Egyptian organ work and
attitude
yeah but these communities don't have a
lot of money to spend in the schools
in college and so
I guess they're not making sense here oh
you you are but if you were to look at
yeah
of how while the schools joint bars and
the indicator of college
money their parents have well I think
that a lot of kids going to the
community college system now you notice
those coming out of vocational education
CTE program as mentioned this morning
that they're coming out with uh
75 percent of the kids are going on to
college from the CTE programs their
scores are five percentage points higher
than the scores coming out of high
schools they're also coming out 100
percent with skills and job opportunity
in terms of the foundations you spoke
about
um when I met with a group of teachers
this last week and we were talking about
um preparation and what's going on in
mathematics to high school it turns out
that after the talking with these Math
teachers from the middle and there's one
two three four five of them there
through high school that
the foundation wasn't really what they
wanted to see coming out of the
elementary schools
so it's not necessarily we see the
waterfall effect at the sixth grade
seventh grade where the scores start
dropping
but it's is that where we have to start
um
[Music]
it's a lack of Communications in the
schools
we got to ensure the academic standards
set for the third grade by the state are
being taught in the third grade
or in accordance with competencies they
may and where the child is it may be a
spectrum in all blocks along the way but
this go ahead
representative representative Cornell I
schools
[Music]
and I know kindergarten teacher and
Manchester who's beside herself because
the kids came in not knowing their
colors because they're coming in from a
totally
Grandpa whose parents probably are
thinking about where are we getting
tonight's dinner uh or where are we
sleeping tonight because there's couch
junk
coming in
the garden of Glory knows how to read or
do you
have advanced programs well this school
is having to deal with well listen
so back to 1680 here
but you know no the discussion's a good
discussion
um
I think kids
may be concerned some of the curriculum
Community College are so strong so well
founded kids look to go to that program
uh not even
um
see when that when that sequence was
supposed to have been taught by whom it
was supposed
to talk
um
they have no receipt where it was missed
from them
um I'm not particularly trying to
explain to people where was it myth in
the curriculum but we're through with
the remediation so you still can do that
um and that can be a complicated but now
you look at you're talking about the
vehicle look at the often you were
talking about the amount of remediation
needed at the four-year institution okay
so these are portfolio causes
accumulation and it was like what
station would that be answering come
from he's missing skill X Y and Z and
it's not to look at that way that those
school systems need help now I go to
school that perhaps the only expensive
their analysis but equal to the college
really tight when you look at the real
enrollment remedial of course they
require and then you look at what school
on
leonson's Campground but that does give
us a space that's the base if these kids
are not prepared
and then that's the schools that need
additional help so it is one level
accountability enough
and so we decided like doe and other
people have
instructions
thinking it's got aligned with things to
do if you want to have to stand up uh
and that's fine but we can't find food
that's optimistic so they're basically
yes it comes into Driving School school
and they don't have it right away that
school needs additional support maybe
create a Pre-K
um along the way that's not telling you
as many different than the data problems
so the Manchester United need more
support more resource
um so it's a little way to bring my
stuff down but I think we should become
lost in the goal of this uh
CA which is the move forward through the
scientific resources done because
there's no reason to be no risks being
representative on that on that point one
of the things I think you'll find in
other states
that have greater that have greater
funding for schools is that they have a
greater Hammer yeah I'd use that term
but have greater resources and greater
Hammers and greater
resources available to schools that need
help
and I think what 1680 is trying to do is
to try to take again the current amount
of money that we have
and how do we allocate that and Target
it more
so that in those districts that need the
additional help they can get the
additional
I mean the handovers and the hopkintons
and the Portsmouth they're going to go
on they're going to be okay
but when you begin I mean we use this
when we were dealing with the uh in 2018
on the uh the uh funding uh
Commissioners Rick and I were on one of
the things we discovered was that a
place like Claremont for example
Claremont had five different
superintendents in six years
now there is no leadership there at that
point in time
principals no no who who to turn to
school boards have a problem with that
and that all goes back to the issue of
where the front where the funding is
there and so I think as it as we look
it's a systemic kind of a look that we
needed to review here and I think that's
what 1680 is trying to do is trying to
look at it from a systemic step whether
to provide greater resources Mr chair to
make sure that there's an equal
educational opportunity for
representative Ames yeah I just uh I
don't want to get out of my depth here
and you guys are way over my head
um but there are two sections in 1680
that seem to be very relevant to this
discussion and one is 11.
um page
10. it's the first one so the first one
is about underperforming schools
and there's a there's a process called
for in this uh in this uh bill
um that would look at uh that would
require the Board of Education
Commissioner of Education to have a
system that would be developed that
would use student performance data and
their is not just one piece of data one
measure of performance that's across a
range that would be selected and to to
determine if there are one or more
schools out there and of course there
aren't
um that are quote underperforming and
then it requires a process to adjust
that so that's the first thing I wanted
to point out and then section 13
section 12 is basically responding to
that underperforming school situation
section 13 is persistent disparities
and this relates more to groups of kids
student subgroups that are persistently
notwithstanding the
new uh system for allocating funds uh
not doing so well
um so persistent disparities and again
uh there's this identification process
using measures that are sophisticated
that are not just outcomes on a
particular test but across the range of
of measures
um and identifying that there are these
persistent disparities and and
developing a plan I think there's a
three-year Plan called for in the bill
to address
um the persistent disparities so I just
wanted to throw that out there without
uh getting into the weeds of it because
I can't handle that but this is a a bill
that is not simple it's it understands
and addresses and calls for people to
address the complexities of of children
in our society and I'm bringing that to
them an education that's going to be
adequate and sufficient to enable each
of those children at least have the
opportunity to come through the whole
thing
1680 is a Reformation
it's a Reformation of how we fund
schools in the past when we were on the
study committee on 2018
we tweaked it on the site I had a little
bit here a little bit there
this is a reformation and it has to have
a very serious look
because it can it can create a whole
different way of funding schools that
will take us in the in the 2030.
I I don't want to minimize this because
this is not a tweaking of the system
this is changing the system and that's
why the serious study of this is so
important because if we are going to try
to maximize the current funding system
that we have in a different way it does
take deep thought
and deep consideration as we move
forward rather than just continue to do
exactly what we've done in the past
do you feel comfortable
um
with the amount of money that we're
allocating in this
and towards that performance outcome
based upon
the data that we've been able to extract
from the doe 2820 form yeah I think so I
mean I I think that the now granted
there are there are uh gradual increases
that are going to take place as there
would be in anything but as a matter of
size you look at that pool
how do you allocate that pool
differently
and that's what so I as as air which is
the outside group remember this is the
outside group the first outside group
since Ogden blue
and Ogden Blick was in what mid 80s so
over 40 years is the first time we've
had an outside group come in look at our
information look at our data
and basically say here's how you can
take that current data
and deal with it in a different kind of
a way than what we've done in the past
and so that's kind of why I'm excited
about this because I think I mean little
did I realize when I proposed this thing
on the floor of the house that I would
get to where it is right now because it
has created the conversation that's what
we try to do here Rick is to create this
kind of conversation about where do we
want this funding of schools to go in a
deeper kind of way than just tweaking a
little bit here I will say that that
representative umberger I think she did
a very good job in in the in the group
that that we worked on Ricks we had a
lot of data that came in and a lot of
people bring stuff in but in the end
we wouldn't take that step
we said no little here little here which
is exactly what we've been doing since
Claremont won
I mean the the courts have told us to
fix this damn thing
and there and the legislature has been
has refused
to take what this courts have said to us
and and create a different system well I
I wouldn't go that far and say the
legislatures refused well I get a little
excited yeah okay well what I'd like to
do is ask you a question does the doe 25
form
the results we get
disaggregate the costs associated with
the adequacy
adequate adequate education from other
costs which are not necessary for an
adequate education or are you relying on
the total average of the doe 25 form
tuition cost which it appears to me we
are doing that we didn't disaggregate
all those components that contribute to
an adequate education referencing 193e I
think that's one I think that's one of
the things you need to look at I mean
for example because having a swimming
pool
add to your education I mean I don't
know how that would fit into the
form 25 but I think that the air has
looked at some of that stuff and we can
get them back in here and look at it
again that the uh the department upgrade
updates their data every time they have
those forms that do come in so my sense
is that we should be able to look at
yeah I I would think that's a necessary
component we need to do however I don't
know if doe has that the the when this
information comes in
it takes their assets it takes their
revenues it takes their expenses that's
the doe 25 form and it has like you say
the swimming pool program in there as a
football program in there which are not
related to
well they're they're related in a long
distance way because I'm I'm always been
a proponent of co-curricular activity
but it's not necessarily going to
contribute to the the results that we
see on the Statewide assessment of
language arts reading and Mathematics or
to the results we get on the SAT or the
ACT
yeah
so I I think that that's an area that
you know anything that moves forward I
think we got the concepts many of them
sprinkled through here are Concepts
which I think we can all latch on to the
the data that we're getting is the day
only data available at doe so that's
what we've got to use and
um I'm not so sure that you know um I
feel comfortable
with you know jacking the cost of an
adequate education up based upon
something which is not related to an
yes representative welcome
sorry I was over in the other room
waiting for you guys and working on this
and fell asleep and I'm like where is
everybody but
um I the section that he was calling our
attention to section
um I can see that as being useful for
every single School
why do we have to wait for a school to
fail three years in a row or whatever
before we start doing that that's the
kind of stuff we need now is what are
you spending your money on what plans do
you have how are you using it how is
this affecting the education all that
kind of stuff I could I mean I would
love to that section in there just put
it in and require all schools to do it I
think it would be excellent
what are the comments from the committee
today
what for the comments yeah
okay thank you thank you
um
what what we have is the next date for
this subcommittee to meet
was is going to be immediately following
the co-op bills which are heard at on
the 12th which is a Wednesday at 9 30 so
we will tie it in so I would say
probably the co-op bill should go fairly
quickly I think we're almost there with
those so I would say by 10 30 we ought
to be ready to
take 1680 this will be the last
subcommittee of 1680. we will be making
recommendations for to the full
committee for action and that full
committee has been scheduled for the
24th of October seeing later that week
all reports have to be done for further
for the calendar and what's the date
pardon me date for which one the 24th
the 24th of March no the one you were
talking about the co-op bills and then
at 10. yeah that's on the 12th of
October
yeah you said Wednesday but I didn't two
days after Columbus Day yeah
and then
it's it's already in the calendar the
24th in the calendar right this dates I
don't think in the calendar the 12th for
the 1680 oh I got that in there great
thank you
okay if there's nothing else thank you